senator Kirsten Gillibrand has just
dropped out of the 2020 Democratic
primary she apparently did this by
Twitter he is not going to she was not
gonna make that debate she had signaled
I think last week Jason she said that
she would be open to being somebody's
vice president which I think that was a
signal so what I by the way is going to
drop out not gonna make the debates I
talked to her today about it and I think
she's got a prong she's got a strategy a
little breaking news later dinner that
we'll get into a little strategy because
she's not gonna make the debate but
she's got a plan ya know she's gonna any
thoughts about her deciding to drop out
it's a realistic viewpoint she never
caught on didn't have a message that
resonated and she can blame a lot of
things but it just did not work and I
think it's better for her in New York
and everybody else that she's there
don't say that to Gregg it resonated for
Gregg no no he's talking about
Gillibrand there were people in New York
starting to say excuse me like you know
you're not gonna become president why
don't you focus on being here at home
yes trimming the fat is always good I
think others should take note definitely
and even like without the CNN climate
change thing they get a comment about
our wait Emily I'm not an amazing
package on homelessness we'll continue
to cover that here and thank you for
going out there and doing that the news
is kirsten gillibrand
the senator from new york will no longer
be a part of the 2020 democratic race so
I think now there are 20 yep
just 20 more to go